how's going red - we're back welcome
back to some more happy wheels toilet
paper leading don't worry by bro I mean
the little piece of [ __ ] but this flight
scam is shut up
I have to take a [ __ ] brazen there is
toilet it looks like I have a black
dildo in my butt God and I please shut
up
so annoying why don't you don't what is
it yeah dancing dancing
I not dancing anymore
just stay right there a little bit
[ __ ] upside down don't ride your elf
nice front fit though took a [ __ ] to
your knee didn't yet know totally paper
here [ __ ] ah alright where are we
going front flap ah
so annoying ah here we go never got
ladies bathroom girls don't you toilet
paper
obviously ah [ __ ] me finally at pain
poop what goodbye son alright where's
the bathroom
how much farther now stop time what one
month later I have to take a [ __ ] ah
tenemos popping again
Chico's peanut man um what your muchas
gracias
ah toilet paper
bike why the [ __ ] are you going dad you
forgot me ah okay I got toilet paper now
I was a good man
such a good nothing here hiya Peck yeah
goddamn it I knew that was gonna happen
sooner or later son of a [ __ ] alright
then someone should make a scary man I
mean you can do it now that there's like
well obviously anything will work for me
no [ __ ] glass run please stop making
glass run Maps impossible harpoon
anything is possible then what my mom
said before she made me clean like I
can't clay on sake whoa time here from
you got a penis extinguisher Wow
yes I'm glad you love your new penis
that's fly haha
right up into that you gotta wait for
the chart
Sanjay Brown flap to the bait
we roll hold by the [ __ ] getting a
little tired of this sorry all right
dad I'm scared of the Caesars stairs I
don't care front flap shut up yeah let
me penetrate hmm don't scratch my ass
I'll buy good oh yeah yeah under floors
lap dad gave me some more slap dad tell
you now listen to that [ __ ] in it I have
a dolphin I'm a dolphin and I'm going
you know why I tell you why cuz you
can't send us out of the joke but I we
never fight a fuss we never could shut
up you never cut your cuts would you
stand on the side it's do it right do it
again Ramallah bye and good about about
[ __ ] you're not kept Shing up out of
hang [ __ ] off I get him honor by and
give one big push for all mankind ain't
nothing to it I just go ahead and do it
I'm a seal [ __ ] I'm I see you
I'm I see I'm sick like I'm yeah funny
I'm so gay everyone look at me
I love paid us this is yo shut up
there we go God said I'm never gonna
finish that one alright here we go again
let's go son let's go don't sing awesome
ah [ __ ] here we go damn it whoa I got a
chair go chat I believe in you I believe
I can chair
that was not as fun have a guy my aunt
always [ __ ] it up
see you later [ __ ] ah [ __ ] stop
mother of [ __ ] arts shot of a barrels
everywhere I'm praying I'm praying
frontlet
okay that was dis [ __ ] let's just
[ __ ] do it
see I'm gonna do it him first right I
bet you're like Peter Pan you [ __ ]
around too much no I don't you know why
I shut I became a chat I'm a [ __ ]
train [ __ ] that didn't last long
this is difficult I take everything I
said back alright there we go there we
go there we go no no no no yes yes no
yes yes front flap I don't care I'm a
sail soon you will never be SC you shut
up yeah I can make dream Cateye oh okay
I don't know what that was I'm sorry but
that was close enough to finish it
happy war I like a wonderful day ah [ __ ]
a lamp I don't know why he wouldn't do
that
no my flange what David plant alright
damn it my plant died oh well it's still
a beautiful it would best story ever
still a better love story than Twilight
alright alright Brea's I read so many
comments to play the Slender map so I
gotta do it I do it
my leg fell out for no reason but I do
why do you even have a sword in your
face huh that's racist
let's watch me watch oh that's how I
roll
now you can't stop her I'll kill you
stop where my son will turn gay wait a
second he's already error why error what
the [ __ ]
slender sorry I hate this map as well
maybe but [ __ ] the arrow alright alright
collect all the notes this is just like
the real slender - is what happen to
people who are scared of Slenderman are
you still scared yes I'm super scared
yeah oh you're such a [ __ ] holy SH ed -
mater
I did not expect that no I did it I hate
you slender I hate you
even in happy we'll see haunt me why
would you do all right fly over the
black guy
whoa I don't get oh alright there you
are get back on get a life and now we
got it Matt we got it now we gotta come
here slender you think you got [ __ ] on
me well I got [ __ ] in your face that's
why you don't have one hahaha I'm flying
alright there we go not too fast now not
too fast
alright there's mr. chary back off I
guess people go in here hello there it
is what is it doing peeing
alright here we go
what sorry alright try again what [ __ ]
that we go to the barracks ah the giant
bullet helped me I can't help you giant
bullet wait why is there an oath on the
fat lady no no bad in slender I said I'm
just kidding oh I got it pin 5 you
readings thanks yah
don't worry bro don't worry oh yeah
backflip alright there's no sound in
this one what are they doing alright I'm
not gonna
what you're doing back there but it
looks like iesson
what are you doing back there holy [ __ ]
I got it I did keep all right I stopped
no oh my dollars oh sorry about that
bruh sorry
ah come on [ __ ] son what happened
alright I gotta fix that that's just
[ __ ] boost our way through all this
that's how I know the [ __ ] want shut up
get out of my way
my deaf daughter you're doing later I'm
trying to draw it do my job man holy
[ __ ] it's like cut the Murray fever gone
ha taxi run flap that didn't work did it
shut up yeah yeah that's how I roll
that's how we get done tonight s you say
that your son's dead leg [ __ ] what is he
doing now giving you a bj yeah Beata
what is your son's leg do it in my I can
do this I can do this I can really
back [ __ ] finished it [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah you like that by you like that
British and Radha what what oh yeah
seems good thing you're so good at
anyway instead I asked you better
believe I'm good at it
okay wait I have to stop recording
all right so happy wheels is really
buggy right now I can't load any more
maps so that's gonna be it for today
like it's our anniversary so my
girlfriend bought me one of those radio
planes it's gonna be awesome I'm gonna
fly one later when it's charged but
anyway like a favorite if you enjoyed
subscribe come on birthday and I'll see
you next
Africa bun Lake - I know you wear that
it I'm finding it ha I feel bad for
Young's in a mission I don't like I feel
like he doesn't get the credit he to
talk didn't meet the [ __ ] chicks and
Bob
okay don't worry about it rest we will
take the bucket and we will fill it with
coffee and that's it
that's all I got